hey everyone this is Kevin from the
chesswebsite.com and today we're going
to be going over the Vienna Gambit which
starts out with E4 E5 Knight C3 after
Knight F6 white plays the move Pawn F4 I
like this because being a player that
has played a lot of Kings game but
anytime I can play E4 and F4 I just feel
extremely comfortable now the variations
we are going to look at one is if they
counter in the center with D5
we'll also look at D6 pretty common line
that black would play anytime white
plays F4 and then we'll also look at the
accepted line the pawn takes on F4 so
let's start with D5 okay they counter
attack in the center of the board but
we're gonna take on E5 usually you're
giving up the pawn on the file that is
the Gambit itself so hey if they allow
us to take material
with our f-pawn and we can attack our
opponent's Knight that feels like a whim
now as far as what they do with their
Knight more than likely they need to
just take here on e4 if they try to get
too cute you know Knight to G4 because
the Knight is being defended by the
bishop on C8 it doesn't really work out
that well for him we can just take with
our Pawn on D5
we have three Central ponds they have no
Central ponds now our Queen is still
attacking where do they really go from
here maybe they take with their Knight
on E5 but then we could just play D4
we're completely controlling the center
of the board they're just going to be
moving their Knight around we're gonna
play Knight F3 we can get our light
Square Bishop involve into the game
Castle on the king side with our Rook on
the f file
they just really haven't done anything
and they don't have any of their Central
Pawn so I do think that more than likely
they are just going to take on uh E4 and
in this case we can play D3 now you do
have some other options as far as where
you can go I like D3 because it allows
us to play some more of the Trap lines I
always like to put my opponent in some
difficult spots now from here that I
think you're gonna see two options one
is if they just take with their Knight
on C3 and they could also play a line
where they play Queen to H4 so let's
first look at the Knight takes on C3
we're going to take with our Pawn then I
think they're more than likely going to
play Knight C6 getting more Mito
involved into the game attacking this
Pawn on E5 we're gonna play Knight F3 we
need to get our own material involved as
well as defend this Pawn on E5 and then
D4 from black if they don't I think that
would be a mistake because then we can
play D4 we can get our light Square
Bishop involved Castle on the king side
I think we have a much better position
part of the reason they're gonna play
Knight to C6 is because one yes it does
attack here on E5 but it allows them to
push forward with D4 and this Pawn is
protected by the Knight and the queen
right here
from here we're gonna play Just Bishop
E2 preparing to Castle on the king side
and really start to put pressure on this
F 7 Square now if they don't play Knight
takes on C3 another option they could
have is Queen H4
okay yes we're attacking their Knight on
e4 but now they have check and we
essentially have to play G3 and they can
just take with their Knight right here
because we can't recapture I think you
just take with their Queen on H1
but after they play Knight G3 we don't
have to capture with our Pawn we can
play Knight F3 so yes they can take our
Rook but then we can take their coin
they don't have a lot of good options
with their Queen they don't just want to
come back uh off the H file because if
they do we just take their Knights on G3
so more than likely you're gonna see
Queen H5 Queen on H6 would fall to our
Bishop on C1 so typically not going to
see that
but now we have the move Knight takes D5
and we are threatening Knight takes on
C7 and this is checked this is also
forking the king and the Rook on A8
now they can take it they want to on H1
we can take on C7 as you would expect
maybe King d8 we take on A8 and then
Bishop G4 we play Bishop G2 attacking
the Knight and defending our own Knight
on F3 but even if they don't take on H1
they could just bring their Bishop down
to G4 right away well we're gonna go
ahead and take on C7
and after the king moves we could play
Bishop to G2
um yes they could take our Knight if
they want to uh that is fine but we're
kind of in this predicament of okay if
you want to take our Rook we're going to
take your Rook if you don't take our
Rook we're not going to take your Rook
but we do want to defend this F3 Square
we need our Bishop and our Queen both
defending that square so that's what
happens if we see D5 early on from our
opponents the next variation that we're
going to look at is instead of D5 they
could play D6
in this position we are going to play
Knight F3 and they have a few options
here they could take on F4 they could
get their light score Bishop involved
it's the game one of the reasons you
play D6 is to have a solid Pawn
structure in this Center very defensive
and then get the light Square Bishop
involved very very quickly they could
also play more of a wait and see
defensive approach with Bishop to E7
this is a safer path the castle on the
king side and yes they may not be
familiar with the Vienna Gambit but it's
very difficult for black to really get
out of line with anything that white can
do so the first option is just the pawn
takes on F4 now as soon as they do this
this is opening up for white to control
the center of the board so white has a
couple options they always have Pawn D4
controlling the center with two Central
pawns and opening up for the dark Square
Bishop to come to F4 so that's going to
be priority Numero Uno but white also
has the option of Bishop to C four as
soon as black has committed to the dark
squares in the center Bishop to C4
always makes sense this is if you played
a lot of Kings Gambit before or just
play F4 in general preparing a castle on
the king side you want to get your
material involved we already have Knight
to F3 then lightscore Bishop Castle on
the king side really prepare an attack
on the f file so Bishop C4 does exactly
that now instead if they don't take on
F4
maybe they play Bishop G4 okay well now
we can still just play Bishop C4 or we
can just play D4 we have both of those
options
If instead they play more of a waiting
move Bishop to E7 now I do recommend
playing Pawn D4 the reason for that is
they're looking to Castle on the king
side they're gonna have King safety
Bishop C4 doesn't do as much still a
very strong Square for the bishop to go
to but just not as much as controlling
the center of the board right away now
if they take we have a couple options we
can take with our Knight we can take
with our Queen
so last thing we're going to look at is
If instead of they play D6 they could
also just take on F4 I do think this is
one of the worst options just because we
can just push forward with E5 and we're
essentially forcing them to come back to
G8 yes they could play Queen to E7 and
say ha I got you you can't take with
your Pawn because that's pinned out but
then we just play Queen E2 they look at
the board and they realize okay now I
have to play
Knight back to G8 and they're in a tough
spot because we play D4 and we control
the center of the board our dark Square
Bishop can now come in take on F4 and
this is not going to be good for black
so really after we play Pawn E5
they're forced to come back to G8 and
then we can play Knight to F3 we can
push forward with D4 get our light
Square Bishop involved into the game
Castle on the king side this is exactly
what we're looking for when we give
compensation into Gambit we want again
in Tempo we want to control the center
of the board and that's exactly what
this variation does so if they take just
push forward you can see they have
nothing developed on their board right
now we eventually are going to be able
to take this Pawn on F4 and we should
have a pretty aggressive game so this is
the beginning hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video and I'll see you in the next
one